you play a woman much older than
yourself in this movie we have a picture
of you here you're the nurse and what it
must have was it kind of freeing to play
this person I loved it that's really
what I was looking for was some kind of
a physical transformation to be a
completely different character than when
I usually play and the nurse is that's
what she's called the nurse is a seven
year old lady who's been shut-in for the
last 20-some years at this old downtown
20s building that is now a hospital for
criminals it's a hospital exclusively
for criminals yes it's a membership
hospital yes it's sci-fi so this is
what's about to happen in the next ten
years and these are criminals that are
there they they want to be people are
trying to get in to get treatment right
you know you get a few bullet holes and
that's really what she fixes up is a lot
of bullet holes and they all come in and
there's different rooms and the rooms
correspond to places like Acapulco or
Niagara or Waikiki and they get called
Waikiki in Niagara in Acapulco were you
were you drawing on someone or anyone
I'm taking for this character because
it's such a specific person I love it
no I wish I was I should have thought of
that I know you know I just kind of read
the script and then I do what I think is
right and her she was very specific
character so it was it was easy to find
it yeah she's tough she's very tough
stuff and she you know she's got a fat
pad and some glasses and semiology
what's yeah did you ever we ever tempted
to leave the set dress like that because
you could probably walk around and no
one would know it was you and you could
have this know about that I would love
to tell you that it was like seven hours
of prosthetics but it really wasn't it
doesn't take that long to it old okay
yeah okay I just need three tequilas
people like let me help you old man all
right we have a clip here from hotel
Artemus let's take a look right now
there for you member 60 and we're off to
the races
you're peachy
how about the no-goodniks it's fine -
you're up nickel swipe no dice lately
the thing is covered in blood
it's always covered in blood I got tips
got lost
yeah well that could be from any darker
my country fine I'll pay you then all
right that's against the rules
yeah I gotta run checks you could be a
serial you could be a pede you could be
a terrorist
that's plenty no the hospital zone where
the cops are looking for you see that's
their job ladies people like us up Jase
you raising your voice to me that is
also against the rules do not kill the
other patients
you know why they call them Everest yeah
I think you do so obviously WWE star
Dave Bautista in hotel Artemus Everest
what was it like working with him oh
he's the best
she just nicest guy you know massive
tattooed buys to have my SEPs isn't that
amazing I always found the same thing
Andy you'll agree we had over the years
over 25 years we've had all these the
giant guys the guys that come on and
they look like they just crawled out of
hell and they're here to wreak vengeance
on all of us they're always the sweetest
people yeah he's adorable and he's
really like we do have this really fond
mother-son relationship in the movie and
you know I always feel bad for him
because he's always sitting there with
like a plastic tub having to eat because
he has to eat all the time
just well he's got he's got he's got
like the muscle mass of 15 people so
he's constantly has to be refueling
himself what's he eat I'm bad looking
stuff just like boiled eggs but not the
good part right you know chicken white
pieces of chicken and it's just so sad
and he's just kind of Chum if you really
want to torture him you just walked by
with like you know an enchilada or
something you're a nice person go by
with your cane and enchilada yeah yeah
come on ahead check this out
you